the janus point it's a startling new
glimpse into an alternative theory
of not only the origin of the universe
but of the origin of the arrow of time
itself
suggesting that one of the greatest
mysteries in all of physics could be
solved with a revolutionary new proposal
from julian barbour who's today's guest
on into the impossible come along and
experience this journey in what lisa
mullen called a rare combination of
humanity and a perspective coming from a
lifetime of the study of history and
philosophy of cosmology julian barbour
writes a book that is both a work of
literature and a masterpiece of
scientific thought come along on this
journey into the impossible with me and
author julian barbour
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to a very
special episode of the into the
impossible podcast
featuring renowned physicist julian
barbour
who is reaching us all the way from the
united kingdom and this is entropy month
and time month on the into the
impossible podcast we had on uh jeremy
england who is not english but he was on
to speak about his book every license
life is on fire
and we have carlo rivelli who's written
many books on time
and we'll have craig calendar's
wonderful book who wrote a graphic novel
about time but today we're talking about
a very provocative and new theory
of time and the origin of our wonderful
universe with a real legend this is this
is such a treat for me uh julian barbour
is joining us how are you doing today
sir oh very well thank you and for a
change we've got lovely weather here
it's uh it's been a very mixed year
weather-wise but it's very pleasant
today i even took snooze for an hour in
the garden oh that's lovely yeah we are
experiencing
what is known as june gloom
uh even though it's july uh we should be
frying in july but in san diego right
now we've got may gray and june gloom
and uh it's very it's very disruptive
but we will make it do you guys deal
with it 300 days of the year we can take
a couple days of the year
so i'm just going to read your bio
from the book which you kindly sent to
me about six months ago and i keep
postponing it because of uh various
activities and i wanted to give it the
depths and depth and attention that it
deserved and julian barbour is the
author of highly regarded the discovery
of dynamics and the best-seller
end-of-time phenomenal book he received
his phd in physics from university of
cologne
in 1968 he's a past visiting professor
in physics at the university of oxford
and lives on the edge of the cotswolds
i've never been to the cotswolds i hear
it's lovely and i'd love to see your
garden someday and we're going to talk
about um life and the universe and time
but before we do that
uh julian uh you're so gracious i want
to do what i do with all of my guests
who write books and that's to do what
you're told never to do which is to
judge a book by its cover but what else
do you have to judge a book by when you
see it for the first time unless you
know the author i want to ask you how
did you come up with the title and the
cover design of this wonderful new book
i didn't i came up with the title uh and
that will come out in our discussion i
think
the cover is entirely the work of basic
books uh and the uk edition perhaps i
can show you the uk edition which is
also quite striking yes
there's there's the cover of the uk
edition um oh wow
and there's the back of it roger penrose
saw that cover and said he thought it
was a very clever cover yes
yes it is a lovely work and it's a work
of art as well and i recognize many
names in here
including uh tj kelleher who i guess was
your editor one of your editors i've
known him for several years
myself but i wanted to um to begin by by
discussing the the notion of time and
and where does it come from because i've
had on carl aurora valley i've had on
many frank wilcheck
and i always have these solipsistic or
tautological definitions that i am
forced to use such as time is what
clocks measure according to frank
time is what
increases entropy or is associated with
the increase of entropy according to
carlow clausius and others what does
time mean to you what is is time
fundamental is time emergent and what do
those two terms mean in the context of
time
well
i've been thinking about time now for
close on 60 years
and my ideas have been evolving i have
to say but i certainly
started off quite by chance in
the autumn of 1963.
quite by chance i read an article about
what dirac had said about the structure
of einstein's great theory of general
relativity in which he questioned
whether four-dimensional symmetry was a
fundamental feature of the physical
world and sometime after i read that i
said well if iraq is saying that
shouldn't we start thinking about what
time is
and then i very soon came to the
conclusion that
if nothing changed we couldn't say that
time passed so so the primary thing is
change
what mark said was
it's utterly impossible to measure the
changes of things by time
quite the contrary time is an
abstraction at which we arrive from the
changes of things
and also in mach it was from mach i
learned
the insistence he had on
the relative activity of motion or
position that you define position
relative to other objects and really
ever since then i've been thinking my
question has been what is time
what is motion
uh and
and i'm still working on that and i've
got a wonderful group of collaborators
now some are in their early twenties
uh then i've got some in their forties
and another very good mathematician
who's about sixty i guess uh so it's
it's actually speeding up now these
these things let me make one comment
though about einstein if i may of course
well against mark died in 1916 einstein
wrote a very handsome uh obituary of him
and
among other things he's he quoted that
passage about time that i've just given
and described it as a gem
but if you look through all of his works
everything he did and what he wrote i
don't think you'll find any attempt by
einstein to put that into reality in his
work wow
and what he when he was asked what his
time i think his answer was very much
like what frank wilczyk said it's what a
clock tells
but he didn't but then which i think is
very significant
in his autobiographical notes in 1948 he
said when he'd created general
relativity he'd committed a sin
in that he'd introduced two quite
distinct things one
was the space-time manifold with the
metric on it and then completely
independently he admitted that he was
bringing in from outside rods and clocks
that measured it and he said that's
inconsistent the rods and the clocks
should emerge out of the fundamental
equations of the theory
and and he never did that but in fact i
think one of the things in chapter seven
of my book i do explain how at least
within einstein's theory
rods and clocks do emerge
and that indicates strongly that they
don't exist near the big bang so i think
we have to rethink very radically
how we think about the conditions of the
big bang because there aren't any rods
and clocks there
right and i'm wondering if there's
anything there there or equivalently
at the singularity of a black hole i
want to start maybe even more
more approximate to that to that point
in time if it is indeed even a point
with a question i've posed to all of my
guests uh including sir roger after he
won his nobel prize uh and that was you
know whether or not singularities should
be taken seriously because we know of no
process in nature that is infinite that
is has unbounded size magnitude density
temperature energy
infinitesimal
length scale et cetera et cetera and yet
we talk about things like singularities
somebody said you know singularity black
hole is where god is dividing by zero or
something like that
but we don't really know um the you know
the correspondence of things that are
infinite but we do know things that are
zero and i want to ask you first you
make a large discussion of what you call
the royal zero is that somehow going to
play a role in a new conception of how
we should think about singularities how
does the royal zero figure in it's the
most unique number because it's a number
that is scale free it doesn't need a rod
as you say it doesn't need a clock as
you say there's something special about
zero what role does it play in the janus
point
concept in
well
we would really have to go into uh where
the title of the janus point comes from
so this goes back to the first
qualitative result in
dynamics discovered by lagrange in 1772
when he was studying the three-body
problem
that gave newton such terrible headaches
the earth's sun and the moon
and what he showed was that if the
energy of the system is not negative so
it's either zero or positive
then in the distant past the size of the
system is infinitely great
it comes down to a finite value and then
it rises up again to an infinite value
in the future that's in the standard
sort of newtonian idea of time going
from past to future but you could
reverse it because
time reversal symmetry
and
that point of zero size in the newtonian
representation is what i call the royal
zero but basically i would say
i when i went to study mathematics at
cambridge
they said what is the equal sign in an
equation mean
it means that the two things on the two
sides of that equal sign are exactly the
same it's equality so in some senses
it's
it's saying that this identity now in
fact
i would say rather more than
the size i now think shape is the really
fundamental thing and one should think
more
about in fact
i would even say that
size is is a gauge degree of freedom
it's something we've put into physics
which shouldn't be there
so
i'm going to start with my famous
triangles i'm always illustrating things
with triangles so if
if
i had just three points
three mater three bodies in the universe
and they're at the apex of of the
sorry the three vertices of the triangle
it's meaningless to say what the size of
the triangle is because there's nothing
outside the side outside the triangle to
measure its size
so all you can speak about is the ratio
of the lengths of the sides or the
angles
and if you think about it
we don't see lengths
we see angles because when we look at
the sky when we look at orion's belt
we see that it subtends about
a few degrees but that's a fraction of
four pi
the whole way around the sky
and
i think it should probably should be two
pi shouldn't it
for bias area so
um
the thing that i'm saying is that if you
just look at what the shape does i don't
think that i suspect there are no
singularities at all
hmm
and
is that is that a fundamental aspect of
an error or problem in relativity or in
our concept because i as i know and i
want to talk about artificial
intelligence the problem julian is that
i have about 10 hours worth of questions
to ask you and i only have about an hour
and a half scheduled with you so we'll
try to be brief but we'll also try to
come back to it but i don't know that
infinity should be taken as seriously as
they are and yet they're tr sort of
treated as sacrosanct in physics and we
talk about the big bang singularity we
talk about a black hole's singularity
these are unobservable and we'll get
into you know falsification later on but
um but this notion that that something
infinite can go to become something
finite has you know kind of been
resolved or at least addressed since the
time of zeno and his famous paradox so
you know what extent is in if infinity
uh if zero is real i guess the question
would be one over infinity why is that
not real
well
or one over zero
yeah
one of the problems i'm facing in
talking with you now brian is that my
thoughts have developed quite a lot
because writing that book was
tremendously stimulating and you may
have noticed that at the end of chapter
8 i hesitated a new idea about what time
is so
let me let me
to help me get into it let me talk about
these very remarkable solutions in
newton's theory because i think they
illustrate
how
perhaps cosmology the way we think about
the big bang should be completely
changed
now
in newtonian theory it's been known for
over a hundred years
that if you have point particles
interacting in accordance with newton's
laws
it is possible
that they collide all together at their
common center of mass
and this is called a total collision
[Music]
and in the three-body problem whatever
the masses of those particles
they can either do it on a line and that
was discovered by euler
or they can do it
uh
when they collide together the shape
must tend to be an equilateral triangle
now if you say
that
this
highs has no meaning it's a gauge degree
of
freedom then if the shape stays sensible
and even becomes very sensible and
uniform and becomes an equilateral
triangle when they all collide
that
if you say that the only physical
degrees of freedom are the ones that
describe the shape the angles if they
stay well behaved there's no singularity
so let me hold up this triangle and move
it ever further away from the camera
you see the size change but not the
shape
this to me suggests very strongly that
the shape is the only thing that counts
and this puts this puts a completely
different way potentially on thinking
about
the singularities of the big bang i
won't hazard anything about black holes
because i'm more interested and haven't
i haven't really thought much about
black holes
but i certainly have about the big bang
and i think that's a very interesting
possibility and if you have
uh
if you have lots of particles
there are
many many possibilities for these total
collisions or total explosions if you
reverse them the other way then you get
a newtonian big bang
and in that case
you can start off one of these total
explosions these newtonian big bangs
where the universe is in its most
uniform shape that it can possibly have
that's in
and it it has the shape of what is
called a central configuration it's a
scale invariant quantity you blow it up
as much as you like but the ratios
between the particles just stays the
same
and
basically if you think about the history
of the universe let's just forget about
inflation what we know as a fact is that
a split second after the big bang
the universe was extraordinarily uniform
and it has got more structured in
homogeneous ever since
and i would think maybe these newtonian
big bangs
are a model of the universe when you if
you shall we say you you you put on
spectacles and all you can see is the
shape and not the size of course we
can't avoid
putting in a shape as well i think we're
very
i think the reason why we always imagine
there's always a size to something is
because of the image that's projected
onto our retina
and
that is a so the size of the object is
the fraction of the area compared with
our complete retina
and that's just um if you think about
looking at the sky at orion the nebula
of orion i'm sorry the constellation of
orion
it it has a certain size relative to the
total area of the sky
so i think the bedrock of physics should
be ratios
and
at all stages it should be ratios
and if we're talking about a triangle
representing the complete universe it
should just be the ratios of the sides
or the angles
yes and that brings up a concept that uh
one of my listeners was eager to
discuss with you is whether or not if
time is emergent you know and space time
or somehow
equivalent uh that you know shouldn't
space be emergent in some sense and lee
smallin our mutual friend uh who you
kindly asked a question of when he
appeared on the podcast about two months
ago uh sad to say he has not
reciprocated yet i'll be waiting and
i'll ping him again and see if he can if
he can give us a comment but he's quite
busy but you know he kind of has this
belief as i understand it that you know
that space time itself can emerge from
uh basically fundamental constraints on
causality
uh and so what about space would be
privileged in other words would space
pre-exist time
i
well all science starts with certain
hypotheses and mine is that geometry is
fundamental and actually my favorite
saying is one of galileo's
he that attempts natural philosophy
without geometry is lost
it's it's it's a wonderful saying and i
just don't think
you can do without geometry
uh in fact i would i would retain the
continuum
and all i would retain is angles
and this is actually when you
when you try i mean if you set about
taking out
everything
in the way we think about physics and do
physics and say
what can
what redundant things can i take out and
get down to what
if i go any further i will destroy
everything and i can't i can no longer
walk because i've chopped off my legs
what i want to know is what is the
essential
things and my belief is that it is
actually geometrical relationships
and they can be illustrated in the first
place i think with
particles in space you can do an
incredible amount with particles in
space with
where you have separations between the
particles
and
some separations are greater than others
but the ratio is well defined it's a
pure number that's another of my
fundamental principles the whole of
cosmology and physics should be
expressed in terms of pure numbers now
you can say newton's
the rot set in with newton when he
introduced time and distance so
uh the greeks always said ratios must be
of the same things so you can take
ratios of two lengths
and then you've got a pure number but
newton introduced time as well as
length in in his things so the velocity
is a distance divided by time
dx by dt and that's an improper ratio
so i want to build up what i call shape
dynamics using only
ratios of of really i would save lengths
that's all i think you need you could
probably just get by
or you can get a very long way with a
very interesting theory just using
points in euclidean space
and another controversial statement that
you make in the janus point is that
momentum should not be treated as equal
to position this
if true and if accepted
would up end our notion of everything
from classical hamiltonian dynamics to
the quantum quantum dynamics that are
predicated on such kinds of conjugation
relationships so i want to ask you um
you know what has been the reaction to
that statement that is a very
provocative statement and you admit as
such in the book
uh that your your your courage is
undaunted by the arrows that you might
take but maybe they won't do any damage
because they only carry momentum after
all and momentum is not real
so what do you mean by this that
momentum should be kind of a um you know
treated with a lower priority perhaps
than position
well let me say first of all there is a
a mathematical way of dealing with a
phase space with which has an odd number
of dimensions it's called i think a
contact structure
so there is a mathematical way of
dealing with these things
and
i think the whole problem with this is
that people haven't taken mark's ideas
seriously that
really what happens locally
is
somehow rather is governed by the whole
universe so so mark conjectured that the
local inertial frame of reference in
which newton's laws are formulated is
determined by the whole universe by the
masses in the whole universe and when
you do that
um
time really in that classical picture
before we attempt to get to quantum
mechanics time time in that classical
picture is just somehow an average of
how
all of the quantities have all of the
separations have changed
so you can have a separation of
all of the things so
it just put out objects on the table and
move them all a little bit then each of
them will have moved a certain amount
relative to the
all the others but the totality will
make a sort of a background quantity and
then each of them will have a proportion
of how much it's moved compared with the
others so
you can always
ascribe to an individual particle
what proportion of the change of the
universe it has done compared with all
the others so its momentum is a fraction
of all the others so that's again coming
back to the ratio so
i would say in classical mechanics if
you really want to have something that
locally looks like a momentum
you've got to say it's it's the measure
of how much it has
changed its position compared with how
much all the others have changed their
relative positions
um
i see so
um right and so that then takes us back
to this ratio or gauge free
description um but i also think julian i
often say you know mathematics is highly
uh as highly
abstract in that you've never seen a
triangle um
we can't we can only visualize a
triangle you know i always say if
somebody says no triangles are real i
say what is a triangle way and that's a
nonsensical question because triangles
are you know collections of three non-uh
co-linear connected uh points which are
themselves of zero dimension which is
kind of mind-boggling uh for humans to
envision so um it's curious to me that
uh you can build up shake dynamics and
the reality
of dynamics and and even
concepts like the janus point from
something that's purely imaginary that
you would have to admit doesn't exist in
reality i mean you can't hand me a
triangle you can ask me to visualize it
but can a computer
really handle it no because a computer
has only an approximation a quantized
level to approximate a point as one over
the small the largest number in its
memory bank right so to what extent can
we build up reality on things that are
purely fictional or created by the human
mind perhaps
well
two comments about that
first of all i think
i think all of the great concepts in
mathematics are suggested by our
experience and they're idealized from
from that
and
i think the
the real numbers are a human creation
but i would say let us work with them i
had a few years ago i i had a discussion
with gerhardt tuft the nobel prize
winner i've met him a few times
we had actually about an hour long
discussion and he was telling me about
his ideas he he his ideal is to build up
everything from zero and the positive
integers nothing else he said
so i said you're then like dedicated who
said you know the god created the
integers and the rest is the work of man
mention work
so then i said
yes so then i said yes
but the what is why don't you accept the
real numbers because the real numbers
are a creation of man man is part of
nature
[Laughter]
and he smiled and i think he accepted
that that was not an unreasonable point
of view so we have to start with
somewhere and uh i think there's that
there's a wonderful saying of of poppa
the the um philosopher about
there is no really sound empirical
foundation of what we do in syria we
just drive down piles into the swamp
until they make a reasonably secure
platform and we work on that until we
have to drive the piles further down so
that's very much my my attitude so
um
i will
happily for the moment of moment except
the real numbers
and
euclidean and romanian geometry and
let's see how far we get with that
now a new concept for me at least you
may have written about it elsewhere is
this concept of end taxi can you explain
that and how that is an improvement
because it must be an improvement upon
what we think about as entropy and the
ability
for um for systems to convert energy
into labor or work et cetera so what is
what is end taxi what does it do for us
that entropy does not do
well
let me
let me
go back a bit into the essence of the
book i mean a major part of the book
thermodynamics and statistical mechanics
was born out of the study of steam
engines this absolutely wonderful book
that sadi kano published in 1824 his aim
was to make a steam engine
with maximal efficiency what was the
maximal efficiency that could be
obtained and the key thing about steam
engines is the steam has to stay in the
cylinder essentially in a box now you
read any of the papers of
clausius who first formulated the second
law of thermodynamics
of maxwell of boltzmann
even up to willard gibbs
they all start off by saying we imagine
things like billiard balls or atoms or
molecules
that are bouncing off each other but
they are in a box and they bounce
elastically off the walls of the box and
the whole of statistical mechanics is
based on this concept of a box
and
klaus is his wonderful definition of
entropy in the second law that requires
very careful
passage from reversible passages from
one equilibrium state to another in a
box it's absolutely crucial he couldn't
have defined entropy without that box
and i have read quite a lot of the
literature on the problem of the origin
of the era of time what entropy is and
so forth and you know i have not seen
one single place where anybody has said
does it make a difference if the box
isn't there
it's quite extraordinary
but when you start thinking about
trying to define entropy when the box
isn't there
you're in a completely different
ballpark
if you say that the energy of the
universe is conserved and i think that's
a reasonable assumption
then you can't do all of the wonderful
things you can do in thermodynamics and
statistical mechanics is change the
entropy by compressing the box and
things like that so you've got to look
for some other quantity which defines a
state function the so the key
state function in statistical mechanics
is the energy and then you see you count
how many microstates there are for a
given energy and that's not that much
difference when you've got a quantum
system you count the
in a given interval of energies how many
quantum states there are in in that
interval
but in all of those cases you've got
some system which is either in a box or
it's self-confined
so what do you do if you've got a system
which can expand freely like we think
the universe is doing
so i've
there is a quantity which i call the
complexity which is an extraordinarily
interesting
quantity it's the
ratio of the mean square length
of all the separations between the
particles divided by the mean harmonic
length so essentially
you take the average of the long
distances in the numerator and then you
take the average of the short distances
in the denominator and that gives you
what i call the complexity
and it's a measure
of how clustered a system of particles
is it's also very remarkably the newton
potential the newton gravitational
potential made scale invariant by
multiplying
by the center of mass moment of inertia
which is half the trace of the inertia
tensor
and this is a very very interesting
quantity and it is something you can
call it the intrinsic size of
that universe of those particles so
we've got a finite number of particles
because
the distances between the small
particles you can regard them as little
rulers which are measuring the whole
size so if i come to my triangle again i
can take its shortest side and use this
as a ruler to measure the longest one
so
the triangle has its own size it has an
intrinsic size
and
that same thing i think could actually
serve as a notion of time
and all of this would be in terms of
pure numbers
and that complexity in the newtonian
classical theory when you go from that
janus point of mind or from a total
explosion
that complexity in the classical
newtonian theory fluctuates but it grows
and that's
that's what i call a state function
which grows and then if you look
in these janus point solutions you find
that the
number of micro states in the volume of
what i call shape space
actually decreases it does not increase
so i define a quantity which i call in
taxi well it was coined by my
collaborator flavio mccarty
which behaves in exactly the opposite
way
to entropy so when you take the box away
everything is turned upside down you
have to as kepler said in a different
context we must philosophize about these
things differently
and so
that complexity
gets
goes on increasing forever in the
newtonian system which is unbounded
and as it as it does that the universe
does not get more disordered it gets
more ordered because you find that
kepler pairs form for example kepler
pairs form and when a kepler pair forms
this is i'm going back to when einstein
didn't
say what a clock is
when you're at that janus point the
particles are uniformly distributed and
they're moving more or less randomly
with respect to each other but then in
both directions away from the janus
point
the particles cluster and very often
they will form a kep form kepler pairs
and as that kepler pair forms its
rotation period becomes the period of a
clock its major axis becomes a rod and
the direction of the major axis becomes
a compass
so you've got a kepler pair which is a
rod clock and compass all in one
and relative to it you can see that the
other particles if they're single
particles are moving in accordance with
newton's first law so this is actually
exactly showing what new what einstein
wanted to understand where do inertial
frames of reference come from
and and
what are rods and clocks they emerge out
of a dynamics
and this can all be done with systems
which have zero energy and zero angular
momentum which is what a machine
treatment of a universe requires
everything falls together into pace
placed beautifully
wonderful
so the next topic i want to talk about
is the
notion of a
a cyclic universe or a cycling universe
a
collapsing universe these are literally
as old as time much older than the big
bang concept dating back to egyptian
cosmogenies and other concepts
um which date
you know thousands of years before
the common era i want to ask you
the classical objection if i tell a
normal person on the street who happens
to have an advanced degree in general
relativity i say um i'm talking with a
renowned scientist today about his
theory that predicts that time can go in
two directions at a single point and the
universe's uh
life cycle
they'll say well tommy gold explored
these back in the 50s 60s and 70s and
ruled them out in some sense or they
were ruled out because of the problem of
dissipation of entropy
and the unbounded nature that every
cycle in universe would compile
more and more entropy does the janus
point share anything
in common with a cyclical
bouncing aeon
does it have anything in common or is it
fundamentally different from those
conceptions of cosmogenesis
i would say it's fundamentally different
and
i would say the main significance of
that janus point idea
which i'm increasingly thinking serves
its main purpose is to sh to undermine
the idea that the arrow of time is due
to increase of entropy
and
also to undermine the idea undermine the
idea that you have to impose some
special condition in the past a past
hypothesis as david albert calls it
to explain the growth of entropy so
when i showed that example of of how the
three-body problem behaves and it's
exactly the same however many particles
you have
that is nothing whatever that special
point that special janus point is not
there because of some extra condition
that i've had to put in on top of
newton's laws it's a direct consequence
of newton's laws
uh
virtually certainly every every solution
that is not doesn't have negative energy
has that behavior
and it and moreover as you go away from
the janus point the universe gets more
clustered in both directions there's a
precise way to characterize that
clustering
by a pure number and those defines
directions of time those are arrows of
time that are nothing whatever to do
with statistical arguments it's nothing
whatever to do with things all lots of
microstates being bundled up together so
that you can't see what's happening and
and it's it's just
i think the
one of the main things i feel really
confident about
uh what i put in the janus point is that
it undermines the standard story about
the arrow of time needing some special
condition in the past and moreover that
that increase of entropy is what's going
on in the universe i argue that what is
going on in the universe is increase of
structure it's getting more interesting
and if you just look at me now as i'm
pumped
pontificating brian
compared with what the universe was like
just after the big bang i think i've got
a point it's got a lot more interesting
and a lot more structured and maybe
people are just blind to this i think
i think one of the reasons so the the
point about
thermodynamics it res it seemed to rest
on such wonderfully secure foundations
the impossibility of making perpetual
motion machines
but
but it's still all of its concrete
results all of the solid results rely on
that box you read willard gibbs's great
book published just before he died
he essentially requires he's talking
about a hamiltonian dynamics
and the system must have the phase space
of the system must have a bounded
measure that's essentially putting a box
in
and if you take that away it's just
everything is different
but then i think now increasingly i'm
coming to think that much more
interesting than the janus point
solutions is the ones where it's really
so that's when in the newtonian
representation the size remains finite
at the at the janus point
but if you have these total explosions
which come out of in the newtonian
picture out of zero size
and if you take out the size story it
comes out of the most uniform shape that
the universe can have i think that's
much more interesting but it still
defines an error of time the arrow of
time is just
the universe is going from being
extraordinarily uniform to getting ever
more varied
and that's actually what
look around at the universe and the
evidence from what the astronomers find
and this wonderful telescope i think
you're involved with well all of those
ones down in chile um
just look you take
what they look like it's
the heavens proclaim the glory of god or
something
proclaim my idea that the universe is
more interesting
so let's discuss uh what have been
called the theoretical virtues by
michael keyes no relationship to me but
he has a paper called systematizing the
theoretical virtues and he talks about
what makes a good theory and what
differentiates it from an inadequate or
a subpar theory
and it goes a lot deeper than the
palparian falsification rubric it's much
more thorough
he does involve certain things that i
find controversial such as
uh your theory should strike scientists
as beautiful as that's a virtue as your
countryman paul dirac said it is more
important to have beauty in one's
equations than to have them fit
experiment i i wish i was with you know
as an experimentalist i take personal
umbrage at that statement
i don't believe it i also don't believe
that experiments should be held up as
the cinequa non of whether a theory
should be
should be at least grappled with and i
use the example lately of maxwell in
1860s when he was coming up with the
unified theory of electromagnetism and
his famous equations he wanted a mental
model which uh if employed and taken
seriously would have led to the
falsification
of his ideas because he believed in
vortices and gears and and ether and all
sorts of things so imagine if experiment
if carl popper were around back then oh
no no that's there's no little gears
there's no little whirls and vortices so
your theory must be wrong no so that's
not that's not fair and to be fair to
popper he said things like he
appreciated the steady state and he
appreciated uh other models staying
around longer perhaps than the history
might judge them to be valid because it
impels people to make observations and
you want to correctly test some of the
other theoretical virtues i want to
confront you with and you mentioned you
know observation and we're going to get
to that
the first one of the virtues is
explanatory depth your theory should
apply to a wide range of scenarios if it
is correct
it should also explain data and the
final kind of virtue that i'm going to
talk about is adequacy your theory
posits causes that account for the
effects of the data and of course that
relies on evidentiary data being
available so i want to ask you what are
the observable or evidentiary
consequences of the janus point scenario
whether or not regardless of whether or
not we can currently detect them as you
say
well it certainly
it says that there will be an arrow of
time a very profound one
that that the
it will be inescapable it will be you
know that the dominant future of
of existence in the universe will be
that we will be aware of an arrow of
time
so i think that's that's a that's a
that's a good start
and when we look at data in the universe
of course you know we want to be
cognizant that
that could also be applicable to the
past hypothesis
uh which actually by fiat which we
physicists you know find abhorrent but
nevertheless uh we uh you could also say
that that hypothesis gives us an arrow
of time it doesn't give us two hours of
time and so my question to you is are
there pieces of evidence now respecting
popper that could um disprove that
because obviously it's consistent it's
it's it if i was putting on a critic's
hat i would say well that's a
retrodiction julian you're you're trying
to come up with a theory that provides
an hour of time but what new express
like what can we tell my future grad
students and your grandchildren etc what
can they look forward to doing to
providing evidence or falsification of
that scenario given that we all believe
there is an arrow of time that we
experience
uh is there another um
is there a consequence of the data you
know some limit on black hole masses uh
some limit on minimum number of of
generations of of leptons is there some
piece of data of evidence that could
substantiate it beyond the retrodictive
nature of the existence of an arrow of
time
the the best hope i have is not for
those janus point ones where there's two
sides but where i have these total
explosion ones where in the newtonian
picture it starts with zero size but the
way i think about it it starts in its
most uniform shape
and
i think this is where we have the best
chance of really making some progress
because if this idea is right i think it
should provide a clear alternative to
inflation that at some stage should be
testable because it would show up in the
cmb in the data in the cmb
because
what is
out of that theory it
all that we've got at the moment is the
newtonian theory but we can see
a good chance that something like it
will happen in general relativity that
the that
we're using that newtonian model of a
total explosion
starting with great uniformity to try
and get some idea of what might happen
in general relativity because there's
great uncertainty about the big bang at
the moment
and in a paper by my collaborators
koslovsky mccarty and david sloane
they makes the first progress to showing
that something similar like that can be
expected in in general relativity it's
related to the
bkl scenario when it's quiet
if you're familiar with that uh brian so
and
so
the the the greek the great triumph of
inflation
was to
give these uh
fluctuations the harrison zeldovich
fluctuations out of which
uh then all of structure in the universe
developed and the key thing about the
early universe was that it was very
uniform but there were small
fluctuations with a very definite
structure the scale invariant spectrum
and
the reason why we've come
my collaborators and i to this picture
of this total explosion in the newtonian
theory was a challenge by a cosmologist
at oxford pedro ferreira to see if in
newtonian theory we could find hints of
an alternative to inflation
because inflation has its
triumphs and they're well deserved
but
it it's very difficult to see how it
gets started and my understanding is
this some uncertainty about how it ends
and whether there's internal inflation
things like that now if these ideas are
right
when if and when we get to applying them
to general relativity i would suggest
there will be absolutely no shadow of
doubt how the universe starts
and it should make very precise
predictions that could be verified
in the cmb
so
there's definitely hope there and
it would surely be
i think you have to admit for all the
triumphs of inflation it's it's it's a
bit shaky on its foundations there's a
lot of argument about how you get from
this very symmetric
bunch davis vacuum to astronomers
actually seeing a a a real universe
which breaks the symmetry there's a lot
of question marks over inflation now
if and it's a big if of course and and
it may be decades if i'm if we're on the
right track i think it could be decades
before we've indicated but if we if we
do come to vindication it will be a
clean sweep we we will
start with a a very uniform universe of
necessity it will start very uniform and
then it will get
more
varied in a very definite way
and that would be of course
quite a nice triumph
indeed yeah i think of inflation more as
a uh as a theory of structure formation
than a theory of the initial conditions
of the universe and that avoids you know
having to think about
both its lacunae in terms of inability
to explain itself
without the existence of the multiverse
which i find you know personally
uh more to the unpalatable side as my
viewers will undoubtedly recognize
um and sort of a almost tantamount for a
replacement of a god-like fiat
instantiation of the universe uh with
that you know an infinite number of
creative uh you know forces like many
bubble universes but nevertheless it is
very successful and one of the things it
does predict is that there should be a
stochastic background of primordial
tensor perturbations or gravitational
waves which are obviously one of the key
targets for experiments such as our
simon's observatory and other projects
around the world and the hope is that
you know these could be measured
and that would somehow lead to
confirmation of inflation although which
inflationary model and which multiverse
kind of scenario that is not specified
but
um it makes a concrete prediction it may
not be observable the waves may be too
feeble to leave an imprint the inflation
may have occurred at a low enough energy
scale that even though it did occur it
won't produce anything that we could see
uh nevertheless what does in the janus
point i assume there are no
gravitational primordial tensor
perturbations in in in
well
in the in the newtonian model certainly
not that's for sure uh
there may well be uh in in general
relativity when but
there are
really
a lot of work has got to be done on the
general relativity side of this to
really begin to make progress but i
think it's i think it is definitely
possible there could be gravitational
waves and as opposed to the present
situation where it that magnitude is
unknown
the it's the r parameter isn't it um
this should this should make a definite
prediction i think but this would
require
understanding of all the forces of
nature i mean there is talk of this new
fifth force i mean
it probably would be a complete package
but um
[Music]
there's hope there's hope
and all i will say is it's a completely
different way of thinking about these
things and it's a very simple one it's
just a very clear straightforward idea
to say that
if the universe is
i should say if the universe is
spatially closed it's it's there's
nothing outside it
then
you shouldn't talk about the scale of
the universe and everything should be
expressed in terms of ratios i don't
think you can have a simpler more secure
foundation for conceptualizing about the
universe
than that
and on that basis once you do that
things change dramatically let me go
back to kepler so when kepler thought
about the observations of the comet that
tycho brahe had made he thought that
that implied that the comet must have
gone clean through the celeste the
crystal spheres that carried the planets
so
nothing was carrying the planets and he
said
he said henceforth
the planets must find their way through
the void like the birds through the air
we must philosophize about these things
differently so i see this claim
that get rid of size it's a it's it's a
bogeyman it's causing it's potentially
causing all these problems with
singularities and things and if you stop
and think about it if i may say so it's
blindingly obvious at least it should be
questioned at the most fundamental level
i think it's
i will go as far as saying it stinks
so one concept that's gotten a lot of
attention lately and even i spoke with a
gentleman uh dr steven meyer
who supports intelligent design and we
had a lively debate about that but
nevertheless uh was this board uh
guthvalenkin theorem that posits that
any
expanding spacetime had necessarily a
beginning or ultimate boundary
um
sometimes misidentified according to the
lincoln
as a singularity uh but more properly i
think identified by carol
and others uh including the lincoln
afterwards as a sort of um the breakdown
of classical general relativity so one
of the virtues i think of your scenario
is that it doesn't require quantum
mechanics
uh to be reconciled with gravity and i
always say that until you hand me a
letter from god and it says you have to
marry quan there has to be a quantum
description of of relativity with uh
that's commensurate with all of our
other classical and quantum theories of
electromagnetism and quantum quantum
electrodynamics um the only two regions
where it seems to be relevant are near
singularities which are unobservable so
we have this kind of uh uroburus the
snake eating its tail that we need
quantum gravity to explain singularities
but singularities only exist in regions
that are
in practice and in principle
unobservable so i wonder if you can take
the other side julian do you think you
know argue against your position
in other words a steel man what do you
think are the best arguments that we
need that we have to have a theory of
quantum gravity do you think it's uh
there are arguments to be made that
support the necessity of a quantum
theory of gravity or is it just kind of
part of the appeal that human beings
have to make everything classical
quantum
uh what i feel
definitely is we have to have a quantum
theory of the whole universe
because i mean otherwise i mean the fact
the the facts of quantum mechanics
around us i mean you and i couldn't be
talking like this if it weren't for
quantum mechanics that's absolutely
correct yeah
what i what i do i mean everybody thinks
uh i think virtually everybody in the
field thinks that the problems of
quantum gravity are at their most
extreme at the big bang and also in in
black holes
and for a long time now my collaborators
and i have been saying no
quantum gravity will
the the quantum theory of the universe
will take its simplest form at the big
bang
because their its shape is at its most
uniform and
the quantum issues will become
interesting later on
and we know they're we know they're
damnably interesting now and they seem
to be interesting in black of the
evidence from black holes is that that
they're interesting by by then i mean
with the hawk of work of beckenstein and
hawking um so
that's how i would put it um
and
well that that's all i can say i think
that
we're looking to
turn this upside down there's an
interesting thing i know
uh
color very very very well and i've also
talked quite often with abby ashtakar
and quite a number of years ago this
might be 20 years ago or more
i said to them
[Music]
do you think quantum gravity will
require
a first of all to be in the first place
a quantum theory of the whole universe
or only of a part of it and both abbey
and carlo unhesitatingly said no we can
start with quantum gravity in in a part
of the universe we don't have to have a
quantum theory of the whole universe now
with my machian uh convictions that you
have to talk about the whole universe
i i disagreed on that one there so that
that would be where i would disagree
with with carlo and um
uh abbey
um i think lee has more sympathy
of those three founders of loop quantum
gravity lee is closer to my position i
think than the other two yeah i agree
uh i think the thing that you know
perplexes people and is sometimes used
by proponents of intelligent design and
and proponent religious uh you know
practitioners is is to use this board uh
guth lincoln theorem
um
and uh and use it to basically motivate
a beginning which would then you know be
in harmony with the torah or old
testament uh description in genesis 1 1
interestingly enough that fred hoyle
used to criticize cosmologists who
supported the big bang as being overly
concerned with genesis which i think is
laughable nowadays people don't
associate cosmologists with being
fervent bible beaters but nevertheless
people do use this theorem and vlankan
himself says things that the uh he
doesn't actually believe it leads to a
singularity but he does say that this uh
the entropy uh according to the behavior
of entropy in the observable part of the
universe is many orders of magnitude
lower than its maximum state and the
second law of thermodynamics says that
the initial entropy of our co-moving
region on this boundary not the
singularity but the eventual boundary
that all space-time geodesics terminate
on going backwards
must be lower still so the universe must
have originated in a very special
non-random state of extremely low
entropy
in your mind i mean what is uh what is
the
lacuna the gap the the the problem with
with lincoln's claiming that
necessitates a new interpretation of
time itself in other words armed with gr
armed with an expanding space time you
don't even need to say it's inflation
although obviously the lankan and guth
are huge supporters of that
but nevertheless if you just have an
expanding space time you'll go back to
some point in the past uh and you'll
achieve lower and lower entropy and the
question of course is that uh you know
who who ordered it to be zero in the
beginning but that's that's you know uh
so i guess i'm asking what are the what
are the failings of that
theorem
the singularity theorem which is a
misnomer of bored bluth and lincoln that
that your theory rectifies is it is it
that that it's purely
uh geometric it's scale free it's gauge
invariant is it that it's more an
interpretation
a a difference rather than an actual
physical prediction obviously they would
predict inflationary gravitational waves
because they support inflation but you
believe inflation is not necessarily
mandatory so what are the virtues of of
the approach that you've taken over
there succinctly as possible
well i i come back again i'm going to
get a
verging on on religious now um okay it's
okay we've had on rabbis and and
christian scientists
i
uh
i am very very struck by this idea that
the universe does have a beginning but
it's but it's a very uniform beginning
and
out of that then structure grows now i
recently
checked out the etymology of the word
creation
do you know what it is as a matter of
interest
uh creation the word in in latin or
yeah where
what what is the etymology of creation
well i'll
emerge from or something like that to
emerge uh
you're quite close it actually comes
from an indo-germanic word
which means to grow
it's nothing to to me it's not creatio x
nihilo
it's to grow
now if you think about my idea that the
universe starts
very uniform it's like a flat field with
soil just a little bit of variety in the
soil and then out of that the grass and
the bushes and the trees grow
and
the quantity that measures that growth
is i come back to this extraordinary in
the newtonian theory in the in the point
particle model
the quantity that measures that is this
complexity it does everything at once
it's the size of the unit it's the
intrinsic size of the universe measured
by rods within it
it's the it's the potential energy made
scale invariant i think there's a very
good chance it's got it that it's time
so
so in fact i would say
time is creation because the amount of
creation is literally the time it's the
potential energy made scale invariant it
is really actually rather
if i may say so an attractive theory
it'll be a pity if it's
wrong well at least you're not saying
what uh einstein said on the occasion of
the 1919 eclipse saying that he would
feel sorry for god if the data didn't
bear him out um i want to turn to a
different epoch in the universe when
it's married matter dominated far away
from the radiation domination
of the extremely early universe now it's
matter dominated
and uh and it's growing at a certain
rate but the rate of changes is not
accelerating yet because dark energy is
subdominant
how does that fit in how do you have
periods of contraction or relative
deceleration of rods and clocks
in in your model how can that
accommodate the observations that we
know the universe was much less rapidly
differentially relatively speaking to
today
accelerating compared to what it is
doing now and will do into the far
future
i'll be very speculative here and
just suggest that perhaps the
acceleration of the universe might be
an artifact of
not treating scale properly so
the all i will say is that
first of all it's clear to me that
clocks come into existence later on in
the universe
it's quite interesting and and very
significant in this dude the universe is
as it gets more clumped and mata gets
more concentrated in
into galaxies and stars and things like
that and i think it's quite interesting
that the acceleration seems to have set
in more or less at the time
broadly speaking when the universe
really started to become significantly
uh inhomogeneous
so maybe
i mean dirac and others conjectured that
the gravitational constant was not
constant
and in fact when i was first
collaborating with my italian
collaborator bertotti back in the 70s
it was still experimentally an open
question whether the gravitational
constant was time dependent as dirac had
argued uh now that's been ruled out
however i don't rule out a connection
between the increasing clustering the
the growth of black holes the increasing
number of black holes
with the rate of clocks that these could
somehow be uh that could be some effect
there and that the apparent acceleration
of the universe is an artifact of that
now that that's that's very speculative
but i think it's i don't think it can be
ruled out
and when we look at um the the features
of
uh of the janus point model i think
what's would be very interesting for me
to get is your thoughts on
uh you know the inspiration that you
talked about from leibniz is
uh moanid ology
uh so you know how how did you come up
with this uh as an influence what was
the role that leibniz plays in this
besides you know kind of being
thought of as a counterweight if i'm not
mistaken to newton uh who wrote you know
the calculus as as well as you know what
feynman who plays a role in your book he
called the language that god speaks so
in the one hand we have you know scale
free things you're talking about gauge
and variant objects like shapes
being a primary fundamental monad of the
universe perhaps
but then you have calculus playing the
actual role in differential geometry and
relativity and so forth so how do you
reconcile these two aspects of
mathematics and their usefulness in
physics and as vigner said so
unreasonably so
that on one hand we need that calculus
which is inherently
dimension full
but then these other objects are more
fundamental in your estimation because
they're dimensional less so how do we
reconcile leibniz versus einstein or or
maybe even you know
euclid versus
versus newton as mathematical kind of uh
protagonists
said opposed to that you put quite a lot
for me here yeah
let me
let me say there have been two
uh sort of philosophically speaking uh
there have been two huge influences in
my life the first was aunts mark when i
read him that was back in 63
it wasn't until uh
1977 so 14 years later that i read
leibniz for the first time and he uh
just a few of his philosophical papers
and they made a huge impact on me
they
the thing that he said was that
what he was really attacking was
newton's idea of space being something
like a perfect translucent block of ice
where there was no marks in it nothing
like that and and leibniz just raised
his hand in horror and says if there's
no variety in the world we can't see
anything we can't begin without variety
so
right at the heart of leibniz's
whole feeling is that
we rely on variety we we rely on
differences and then his idea was that
to have a
a world that is more perfect than any
other one
it should be maximal variety that the
variety so
in the monadology he says that the
the universe is more ver we live in a
universe that is more varied than any
other possible universe
but subject to the simplest possible
laws and i found that a very attractive
idea and i uh lee smolin took it over
very enthusiastically and between us we
developed an idea called maximal variety
which still lives on now interestingly
about seven years ago i had an
introduction to the man who had just
retired as the editor of the liveness
papers it's a colossal project
they got to volume 50 when i had lunch
with him in hanover
and
he said and i told him of my enthusiasm
for that idea of leibniz and as i recall
he said to me well leibniz actually had
two ideas
one was that the universe is eternally
more varied than any other possible
universe and the second one is that it's
striving to become ever more varied we
talked a lot about uh some of the novel
concepts in the book i wonder if you
could just briefly recapitulate the two
that are most significant to me
are really in contrast to the so-called
past hypothesis which in uh in in
essence inserts by fiat the low entropy
state of the early universe what is the
replacement of such a phenomenon in the
janus point concept
the first thing to say is that the whole
notion of entropy developed with
thermodynamics out of the study of steam
engines
and in a steam engine the steam must
stay in the cylinder which is
effectively in a box
and the
main starting point i have to completely
rethink the whole story of the entropy
of the universe as opposed to systems
within it i mean the laws of
thermodynamics certainly held in my
kitchen where i'm sitting now
but do they apply unchanged to the whole
universe
which i don't think is in a box so
that's my starting point to rethink the
concept of entropy so
if
i start with the simplest model i can
which is the newtonian theory of point
particles interacting through universal
gravitation and right back in 1772 the
great mathematician lagrange was
studying the three-body problem earth
sun and moon
and he found a very important result
which was it was the first qualitative
result in dynamics it was
in the infinite past as you think of it
in newtonian terms the size of the
system that's its
moment of inertia is infinitely great
as time passes it gets smaller and
smaller it comes down to a minimum value
of minimum finite value and then it
increases again to an infinite value and
i call that minimum point the janus
point now
if you have lots of particles at that
janus point
the system the particles are more
uniformly distributed than on either
side of the janus point
and in addition as you go away from and
they're moving more or less like a swarm
of bees in a random way so you would say
there that their entropy is maximal it's
very much like a lot of
atoms in a box or a free gas in a box
but as you go away from the janus point
in both directions of time
the system breaks up into clusters and
becomes much more ordered
and those that degree of clustering can
be measured precisely by a quantity a
scale invariant quantity it's a pure
number that i call the complexity
that
defines direction of time
bi-directional arrows of time away from
the janus point
and
rather than the universe getting more
disordered as you go away from that
disordered state at the janus point it
gets ever more better ordered clusters
formed kepler pairs form and go around
each other in beautiful uh elliptical
orbits
and
so i would say this is an indication
that we we've got a completely different
story when we think about the whole
universe not being in a box because
the
it is just
quite different that janus point is not
there
for some path hypothesis it hasn't been
had to nobody's had to add it to
newton's equations to put it there it's
there as a direct consequence of
newton's equations as long as the energy
is not negative and even if it's
negative you'll get something like a
janus region in virtually all the
solutions so
this for the main claim i make in the
book and i don't necessarily tie it to
that specific janus point model is a
second one where it's only half of that
javascript so to speak
is that this just puts a really
fundamental question over the whole idea
that the arrow of time corresponds to
the growth of an entropy of the whole
universe and that to explain it you have
to say that the universe started in a
very special way
and some of the um notions that i've
talked about on this channel have to do
with not popper's version of
falsification which i always point out
popper actually thought that the steady
state model or the quasi-steady state
model had some virtues
but actually the virtue of you know
epistemological
uh concision and austerity
parsimony etc but primarily not
necessarily due to falsification but um
but nevertheless due to
the ability for current day evidence to
shed some light or some bayesian you
know confidence on our models are there
predictions of the janus point paradigm
that would lead us to have more faith in
it and is there anything that could uh
falsify it this notion of the
um the the fundamental nature of of
dimensionless objects and and sort of
gauge free objects is there anything
that could
lead more evidence to it that exists
currently or could exist in the future
or is there anything that could prove it
wrong in your opinion
i think there is real hope uh and this
relies on
not taking that particular model that i
showed where the size in the newtonian
picture remains finite but it is
actually zero and now there are these
very so
the basic idea that my collaborators and
i have been following for some time is
to
use newtonian theory to get some idea of
what might be happening in general
relativity at the big bang because
remarkably in newtonian theory and it's
been known for over a century
that there are situations in newtonian
theory
if you have a whole lot of particles
that are interacting with newtonian
gravity they can all collide
instantaneously at their center of mass
at the common center of mass and that's
called a total collision
and
by time reversal symmetry you can
reverse the direction and then it
becomes what i call a total explosion
and the very interesting thing about
such a total explosion
is that it has to start in a very very
special way it has to start when the
particles are in what is called a
central configuration the shape is very
special
and there's one of those possible shapes
which is extremely special which is the
most uniform state that the universe can
possibly have it's not exactly uniform
but it's very uniform indeed and then as
you go away from that total explosion
this quantity that i call complexity the
measuring the measure of the clustering
grows it flu in the classical theory it
fluctuates and it grows
and
now
if something like this happens in
general relativity in in a quantum form
of general relativity
i think this could indicate that the
universe of necessity the law that
governs the whole universe
starts in the most uniform way it
possibly can
but with certain small fluctuations
which then grow
and
if you leave out all the fine details
this is broadly what we know about the
universe so i think there is a hope
that
if these ideas could be developed
further in the context of general
relativity it would lead to precise
predictions about
fine details in the microwave background
and that would be
be a great triumph if it could be done
uh we spoke earlier about the board guth
philenkin
theorem and whether or not that could um
you know be
leading cosmologists to a low entropy
state of the universe what are your
feelings about the board guth blanken
theorem which sometimes improperly is
called a singularity theorem as the
lincoln himself has said it doesn't
really predict a singularity and as sean
carroll has pointed out you know there
are alternatives to thinking about it
and perhaps the best way to think about
it is when classical
gr breaks down one of the virtues of the
janus point paradigm is that you only
need newtonian mechanics essentially
it's very generative and and classical
general relativity but i wonder can you
you know steel man your opponents and
say what are the arguments that you
believe are valid that motivate a
quantum theory of gravity
uh
well
i i think it's it's
in the first place i would say it's a
quantum theory of the whole universe
uh that's uh that's what's that's what
we need i mean certainly you and i
couldn't be talking to each other if
quantum mechanics
wasn't governing the way things behave
right uh that's that's for absolutely
sure this photons coming off my laptop
screen showing your smiling face in
california that's an absolute miracle
so i do believe we need a quantum
description of the whole universe
um but
the point i keep on making is that
the idea that the universe has a size
which is somehow measured by something
outside the universe is just
for me that stinks i think it's just not
tenable
if the universe is a self-contained
object in newton in einstein's theory if
it's spatially closed then any
size it has must be some intrinsic size
that's from measuring rods within it
and therefore the only thing that one
should look at is the shape of the
universe and i don't think anybody is
thinking about that well sometimes roger
penrose is talking a little bit along
those lines but certainly not in the way
that we are so if you actually look at
what the shape of the universe is doing
when you have these total explosions
that start from a very uniform shape
this suggests a completely different way
of thinking about cosmology that the
universe starts uniform you don't need
inflation to make it uniform because it
must start uniform that's the nature of
the law of the universe and it's a time
asymmetric law
in this case where we have a total
explosion it it it's it starts very
uniform and it just goes on growing
getting more structured the the
structures increase and that matches
exactly what we see
if you look through any telescope that's
the story the telescopes tell you
and when we look back in cosmic history
we see after an early period very brief
period of radiation domination the
universe became matter dominated and
there it stood until you know five
billion years ago or so when it started
to accelerate how does entropy behave
and how does the janus point reconcile
the you know the relative deceleration
of the universe if not a contraction
still the um the arrow of time and and
so forth how does that behave in a
universe with um with multiple
components just taking matter and dark
energy which we know to exist
how do we how does that
reckon how is that reconciled with the
janus point um paradigm
well uh
let me say i uh
i have to call it it's the half janus
point paradigm yes
the theory starting with the total
explosion in the newtonia in the in the
standard picture with size it's where
it's the size of zero but i would say
size is a gauge degree of freedom that
what you should think of is the universe
starts in the most uniform with the most
uniform shape it can possibly have
now
rods and clocks don't exist anywhere
near the big bang they only they come
into existence later on as the universe
evolves if the universe is all
tightly interconnected as a machine
relational picture of the universe as it
should be
then
i think it's quite possible that the
apparent except that the accelerated
expansion of the universe is actually
not really there it's because we don't
realize that the rates of clocks are
affected by how clustered the
universe is
and it is interesting that the
accelerated expansion seems to have
begun
more or less at the phase at the epoch
when the universe was becoming
significantly clustered clumpy in
homogeneous so
that's a very tentative idea but i think
it's not impossible
we
we do know that dirac thought that the
gravitational constant was time
dependent now we know that's not that's
ruled out but i think it could be that
there's an overall effect of
the um
it's it's our not understanding the way
clocks work
and um
and also i mean
i do think there must be a quantum
description of the universe but the
rules of quantum mechanics that we find
about us i believe are emergent
so that they don't the the universe the
quantum mechanics of the universe
doesn't look like the quantum mechanics
of the objects the things we study in in
in the universe in the laboratory
and that is matched with
the origin of inertial frames of
reference and mark said
the law of inertia the inertial frames
of reference
they don't hold in
bland
absolute space and time as newton
imagined sort of a translucent block of
ice and a clock ticking away
it independently of anything that's
happening in the universe mark said
somehow rather the fact that the law of
inertia is something
due to the action of all the masses of
the universe on each individual body
and
that is the theory that i
elaborated with my italian collaborator
bruno bertotti back in the
late 70s early 80s and i think that is
the definitive
implementation of mark's principle
mark's idea and i think it's entirely
possible that something happens with
quantum mechanics that the local quantum
mechanics we see with hilbert space and
operators and all that is an emergent uh
effect from
a rather different quantum mechanics of
the entire universe
um
i see
and uh i think the last uh kind of topic
that
i want to get into is uh this very
provocative statement that you made that
that position is fundamental but
momentum isn't and i wonder if you can
answer that in just one second i want to
remind people we're talking to julian
barbour a renowned uh cosmologist a true
remote mentor to me and many people i'm
sorry to tell you julian you're uh you
have influenced me to the good hopefully
uh so i'm going to ask you about the
primacy of space over time in just a
second office yeah you've got to
call it stop at some stage
i could talk to you till the end of time
which uh which could could be a long a
long period of time um so julian now
what i would love to do with you if you
will uh indulge me
is go into the impossible this is when i
asked my guest to honor me by coming on
this podcast
with kind of the big picture topics we
discussed a lot about your
knowledge which is with the word science
in latin cientia means knowledge but now
i want to talk to you about your wisdom
your sapienza
and if we could do that i would be quite
a great thrill to me so would you mind
talking
about the so-called big picture
questions that i always love to ask my
guests now in the into the impossible
segment
yeah that's fine by me yes i'll do my
best
okay here we go
uh so the first one has to do with uh
with
sort of a concept in
in judaism or in uh the philosophy of my
religion which has to do with what's
known as an ethical will
so um
many many decades from now when you
reach the biblical age of 120 years old
and as shakespeare said and you quote
many times from shakespeare in this
wonderful book the janus point uh you
depart
again not for 50 years please god or
nature or janus if you will
i want to ask you what do you want to
put in your ethical will not your not
your knowledge but your wisdom to leave
for future future heirs of the
ideological kind which i count myself as
one
yeah well i did i did uh let me just i
did make
just a few notes because it's quite a
challenge
so first of all when i was
in my late teens i got very enthusiastic
about antiquity and the above all the
greek authors and i picked up from them
two greek sayings
in all things moderation
and know thyself know thyself is that
the oracle at delphi
uh and certainly i think i have i've
certainly done i think quite well in in
all things moderation uh you know i
never smoked i never drank excessively
and things like that i had one of us
and so forth um
know yourself know thyself is
is harder i'm not sure quite how well i
knew myself um
perhaps i could say that i was i used to
be uh not terribly seriously i used to
be bipolar and didn't know about it you
didn't read about those things when i
had it but
by great good luck i i was put on
medication uh back in 2004 after i had
been psychotic which has completely
eliminated all traces of me being a
bipolar you might not have thought it at
times in my thing but it's a it's a
miracle it's the it's the medication
they used to give to epileptics called
valproate they don't understand why it
works for epilep it's an anti-convulsant
but it is it is definitely stabilized me
once i went on to it through a trial i
joined a trial and it it cured me so now
i think i do can say i more or less know
myself
[Music]
so a thing
the other thing that i
i did i was very lucky in going
independent um and i think i was lucky
in my father he'd been an independent
arabic scholar he actually became deputy
head of the arabic service of the bbc
and he may have been a bit of a role
model for me so
um
i would say don't be afraid of being
going independent um
[Music]
i when i got really interested in the
nature of time and motion uh i decided
not to go into academia i decided to go
independent
um felix birani a noticed relative noted
relativist i asked him what it's like
being in academia he said if you can
do the administration
give the lectures
and write one or two good research
papers a year yes if you have doubts
about any of those three no
and i immediately it was clear to me it
wasn't for me because i wanted to study
the nature of time and motion and there
was no way i was going to produce one of
two good research papers a year so i
went independent
and i deliberately took up the most
boring job imaginable which was
translating russian scientific journals
into english i got into it by chance i'd
learnt russian as a hobby
and would you believe it for 28 years i
translated
those journals but it gave me a salary
at least as good as a professor and i
had a third of my time to do exactly
what i wanted
wow
and
i reckon an interesting thing is
i reckon i generated about 70 million
words in english
now
and those are all on library shelves
around the world now if you ranked
humanity in order of how many words they
generated which are library shelves
where would i come i think i've got a
sporting chance to be in the first top
20. i think you do yeah i think yeah it
was it was desperately boring but i
opted for that against trying to set up
a because a lot of people say they'll
they'll go and they'll make a business
make their fortune and retire at 35 and
i said to myself if i tried that it
won't i'll get so hooked by the business
better to have a boring job where i'm
desperate to get away from it and think
about the physics and it worked and then
in 1996 on the 19th of may i said i'm
not translating anymore and i've been
free now for 25 years and i've had 25
years
with really good collaborators top class
collaborators and the ideas are still
coming the the the they're great and
i'll say one more thing perhaps one
there's a wonderful stand-up comedian
paul merton in this country and he
publishes autobiography a few years ago
and i heard him interviewed on radio
because when i went decided to go
independent my family and my wife's
family from germany said you're taking a
huge risk julian
and paul merton decided to become a
stand-up comedian when he was 16 and the
in the interview on the radio he was
asked
didn't that feel risky
and paul said it didn't feel risky it
felt
and i suddenly realized that was exactly
what had happened with me
so my
ethical will
would be
if you really feel something is
necessary perhaps have the courage to go
for it and certainly i've never
regretted it
and um
so then one other thing i will say you
asked what
what was the best job i had
somewhere the best job i had for for
four and a half months i was a weather
observer in the canadian arctic by some
chance i got a job
up just exactly just a quarter of a mile
inside the arctic circle at bathurst or
bathurst bathurst inlet
it's one of the beauty spots in the
arctic
i was there for four and a half months
and the all i had to do every three
hours i had to do five minutes work
which was make a weather observation
at least there's consistency there it's
like san diego you know it's it's
very easy
i absolutely loved it there i mean there
were about a dozen inuit there was a
hudson bay company a man with a hudson
bay and just one canadian i was with and
i took two suitcases full of books and
read them by the midnight sun and for
years afterwards i would say i've got to
go back to the arctic it was so
beautiful but amazingly
uh and this is the thing which i do
think we should really try and preserve
the world it is so amazing and the the
worry of wars and and climate change
i so far as i know the average
temperature at bathurst inlet where i
was for the summer of 1958 is now four
or five degrees centigrade warmer wow
yeah
that is just staggering in you know when
i've gone from
early 20s now to 84 that that is a scary
thought
so that brings me on to
what i would say is
you know uh
well
yes you asked me about i mean you you
suggested i read the uh at the end of
genesis but
um i'm very impressed by another jew
that is jesus and he he summed up it in
two commandments
love the lord thy god with all thy heart
and with all thy soul and with all thy
mind this is the first and great
commandment and the second is like unto
it thou shalt love thy neighbors thyself
of these two commandments hang all the
law on the prophets now i'm agnostic i
have no idea where the universe comes
from why i'm here but i do think it is
precious
and you know
i think it would be an appalling tragedy
if intelligent life
disappears from the universe we might be
the only
place in the universe where it exists
so i think that's very important
and i do think
the preservation of intelligent life and
happiness uh are valuable so i i i rate
happiness very highly so as regards
jesus's second commandment i i accept it
totally i say try to treat your neighbor
as yourself
but make sure that you're happy yourself
otherwise you're just going to be a down
right miserable person right and that's
the people and and i will say of myself
luckily i've basically been a pretty
happy person i've been blessed with a
cheerful
personality it seems yes yes you
certainly have and you are very
influential on me and
literally thousands around the world yes
it is true that uh the commandments are
very
uh
to be taken seriously
means that if you have to love your
neighbor as yourself you know all the
more so we say in hebrew culver homer do
you have to love yourself like yourself
uh but but you know if you have to treat
people with with um with weightiness
with hot with with importance as your
parents and so you should treat yourself
and that's great that you mentioned
self-care and taking care of your mental
health as you did and i imagine that
will play into your advice to your
former self which will be the final
question uh the second question though
is reminiscent of one of the characters
in this book richard feynman who has
many many um appearances in the janus
point and he said if asked to summarize
the greatest uh
amount of information in the shortest
sentence he said that he would sort of
uh
put forth the atomic hypothesis
that everything is made of atoms and
they have electrons and structure and so
forth i want to ask you if you had a
monolith a time capsule like arthur c
clark sentinel
and you could be guaranteed julian it
would last for a billion years what
would you put on it or in it besides a
northern canadian weather forecast
i would put my two triangles yes let me
see them hold them up
so
so here they are now the the
the fundamental question that goes back
to newton and leibniz is
how do you define motion what is motion
so newton invented absolute space and
time so that he could defy so that he
could give a mathematical definition of
the law of inertia so for him
there is an absolute space like a block
of ice
and in it you can draw lines and free
particles will move in a straight line
and leibnitz said this is nonsense all
that happens is there are separations
between particles and they change so
if this is
if at this triangle at the vertices of
the triangle there are three particles
they can move according to newton they
can move in two ways they can change the
separations between the particles and at
the same time the whole triangle can be
moving in absolute space
and leibniz says
no that's no good all that is real is
the changes in the separations now
i do take very seriously the principle
of least action how do you define action
what is the action
when i go from a triangle that has
this size and shape and a triangle that
has that size and shape slightly
different
and
i'm going to say what is the difference
between those two triangles without
using the position that they are in my
kitchen
i'm just going to use the two triangles
so i'm going to say i take this is my
reference triangle and then i take the
second triangle and i lay it on top of
the other one
and try and bring it to overlap to
congruence congruence is the fundamental
principle for making proofs in geometry
so i'm going to try and bring it to
congruence but i can't do it exactly
because they're not the same size and
shape
but but what i can do is
is move them into different positions
and then i can take the separation where
particle one is in this triangle and in
this triangle so there's a separation
i'm going to square that separation i'm
going to multiply it by the mass of that
particle i'm going to do it at each of
those three vertices
and then i'm going to add that up and
then i'm going to move it until i get it
into the position that minimizes that
quantity
and i say that that is the process of
best matching that was what my
collaborator betty and i developed in
our paper published in the proceedings
of the royal society in 1982
and i think i am very confident that
that actually solves the problem of how
you define motion
provided the universe is a
self-contained thing so that's what's
going to go in my
monolith out in there and this there's
quite a nice
i used to travel to all the conferences
with my triangles they were two big
cardboard
um
plywood uh triangles and hold them up
and do that and on google images you can
find a nice color picture of me and
crack off in in poland doing it so yes
we'll include that
monolith in the background
as long as the universe is something
self-contained i'm very confident about
that yeah
it meets a lot of criteria
maybe what we'll do is make your
monolith uh have a triangular cross
section or multiple triangular cross
sections like some kind of
penrose staircase
and the final question
that we ask all of our guests has to do
with sir arthur c clarke's third law did
you ever know sir arthur julian
no i've i've read
one or two of his books i
when i was younger i i did read a bit of
science fiction the war of the worlds
and things like that but um i don't read
any science fiction now but yeah i know
i certainly know of the man anyway right
that's for sure yes so he had many uh
many great aphorisms including uh my
favorite uh from time to time to use
with my colleagues is uh he would say
for every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert
but
for now his third law gave me the name
of this podcast his third law states the
only way of discovering the limits of
the possible is to venture a little way
past them into the impossible
so i want to ask you
what was the
aspect of life that was most mysterious
or most foreboding
intimidating as a 20 year old but now
it makes perfect sense to you because
you had the courage to go into the
impossible
what worried me
i tell you what
i don't think i was ever seriously
worried by anything brian
well i was dead lucky i mean my my
my father was earning good money at the
bbc he'd inherited some money i was very
lucky i grew i had a very stable
upbringing
i at school i was re
i could high jump i was reasonably
athletic
i
now you ask me i don't think i ever
worried about anything i just
i wanted to become an astronomer i got
absolutely hooked on astronomy at about
the age of 10
and until i started asking myself what
is time
and what is motion uh i still wanted to
be an astrophysicist like you or a
cosmologist
but then suddenly these questions came
so i said
i'm just going to try and answer these
questions
so
i i was lucky i wasn't
[Laughter]
is that a satisfactory answer yeah you
knew early on well that's great and you
also gave wonderful advice earlier in
this segment but julian for now i want
to thank you for having uh the courage
the brilliance the insight
to go uh two hours plus with me
in total and uh and i think again this
could be just the logarithm or the
of the amount of time i wish i could
spend with you and i hope i get to meet
you someday soon
all right great good to talk to you bro
thanks very much
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you